[Music]
this is the mekong river in southeast
asia it spans over 2 700 miles and
passes through six countries
and just below the surface of rivers
like this lies one of the most important
resources on earth
sand
and we're running out of it
[Music]
sand or aggregate is a key ingredient in
cement globally it's estimated that we
mine as much as 50 billion metric tons
of sand every year to build our roads
skyscrapers homes and more rapid
urbanization around the world has made
sand a high value commodity so much so
that for some it's even worth killing
for but not all sand is the same and
experts say some mining operations are
damaging ecosystems infrastructure and
putting people in danger and hardly
anyone is talking about it
[Music]
every country on earth uses sand and
it's mined in a variety of places around
the world
it's the most extracted resource on
earth by volume after water and we've
relied on it as a building material
since the dawn of human civilization
sand is a highly valuable resource and
not only sand in general but specific
types of sand so sand chemically
speaking is
very crystalline uh quartz uh silica
sand and there is a certain particle
size uh that is really
required for use in in cementitious
products like concrete so we like
particles of a certain size uh that it's
really great because it's really angular
and it provides a lot of kind of
interlocking effects
at the micro scale level that really
contributes to a lot of the strength of
the concrete so a lot of people will
think well i think there's a lot of sand
in the world just look at all of the
deserts around the world and actually
it's the wrong type of sand the sand
particles are much much smaller and
they're actually rounded due to
weathering so if you were to try to make
concrete with the sand
from the deserts uh it's actually quite
difficult to do you need a lot more
water to get things flowing uh which
will actually compromise the ultimate
strength of the concrete
you've got mountains and other you know
geological formations and over the
thousands and millions of years they're
being eroded by wind and rain and the
elements are constantly
chipping away at those at those giant
chunks of stone breaking off little
pieces grains right the rains wash them
down the sides of mountains into rivers
and then rivers carry them from the
mountains
along across the land and out to the
ocean so all along the way sand is sort
of accumulating at every step along that
process so you have a lot of sand on the
bottoms of those rivers
on the banks of those rivers we mine
that sand uh from basically every one of
those places where it occurs besides
concrete it's absolutely incredible how
many other ways sand touches your life
pretty much every single day we use
standing paint we use sand in toothpaste
it's used in some wines every window
every car windshield the screen on your
phone the silicon chips that run our
computers and our phones and every other
digital goo god that we use those are
made from sand too the elastic band in
your underwear is probably made from
sand
while urban expansion has driven an
increase in demand for sand around the
world over the past few decades that
demand has especially skyrocketed in the
global south as many developing nations
see growing populations and economies
[Music]
macwinnie county is one of the
iridium semi-arid countries in kenya so
mcqueen county uh borders nairobi county
that's
that hosts the capital city the largely
an agricultural community so basically
we rely a lot on agriculture and last
stop keeping for our livelihoods all of
this is rain fed
with very small pockets of
irrigation uh from the small wells and
water plants that collect water during
the rainfall we
have only one permanent river and the
rest of the rivers are actually dry
riverbeds that are seasonal
before the
devolution that is the decentralization
of governance in kenya in 2013 we had
one central government and so natural
resources were managed from the central
government
and sand as a natural resource was
largely um unregulated so we've had
decades of
unregulated and excessive sand
harvesting particularly from the dry
riverbeds it was very easy to transport
sand from mcqueen and into nairobi
the mekong delta is an area that is
about the size of the netherlands about
40 000 square kilometers it concentrates
about 18 million people
it is a food center it has a
much larger
contribution to the gdp
per unit of earth area than the rest of
the country and it produces
enough rights to feed a half of the
country so we're talking about 45
million people on top of exporting to
the world and the wide range from the
philippines to the middle east
production of sand is on the main stem
of the river across the low mekong so it
is not only in vietnam it is also in
laos in thailand in cambodia and in
vietnam and probably the highest volumes
are extracted in cambodia
[Music]
despite its status as the second most
extracted resource on earth there's
actually very little regulation
monitoring or enforcement around sand
mining in many countries around the
world as a result it's difficult for
experts to quantify just how much sand
we truly extract from the earth each
year and it makes assessing the scale of
the environmental effects of sand mining
difficult as well so we extract from the
earth we mine the sand that we need in
lots of different ways in lots of
different places probably the most
common and the most problematic way that
we mine sand is river sand mining
there's lots of really excellent high
quality sand on the bottom of rivers and
it's really easy to get at right all
you've got to do is
send out a big dredge a big barge out
into the middle of that river drop a
pipe down to the bottom of the river and
just suck it up like a straw into your
boat you've got a big boat load of sand
you can take it anywhere you want and in
some places especially in the developing
world it can be literally just you know
a few guys with shovels and a pickup
truck at the other end of the extreme
you've got multinational corporations
that use huge enormous dredging ships
that can pull up sand from from the
bottom of the ocean or from the bottom
of lakes hundreds of meters under the
water and in between you've got you know
every shape and size you can imagine
from smaller ships to
land pits that are dug up using earth
moving equipment
so it really ranges the whole gamut
there are cascading impacts if the
riverbed itself is dredged for sand that
can make the riverbed deeper sometimes
wider it changes where and how water
flows throughout that system and where
and how
sediment flows as things are removed
from the bottom there's different
habitat that is available or no longer
available we had decades of sun
harvesting unregulated
and this led to you know exposing the
the dry riverbeds to a lot of
degradation so rivers became dead of
course that has an effect on agriculture
so we're not able to produce as much
food as they would want naturally large
river systems like the mekong produced a
lot of sediment about 160 million tons a
year but because of harder power in
higher demand for sand there's less
sediment reaching the sea there's mainly
conservation holders
who have concession from the government
and extract sand the problem is that the
monitoring of the extraction is limited
and it's usually self-monitoring so we
believe that a large part of
the over extraction if you want
is the concession holders who under
report and over extract in the lower
mekong we're probably extracting between
80 200 million tons a year we most
probably only have three to five million
tons coming in it's causing a deepening
of the channel we believe that it's
about two to three meters loss of
elevation so that's significant
you have incision of the riverbed you
have erosion you have thinking of the
delta the extraction of sand for
construction is done at the cost of
significant changes in the ecosystem
with high demand and little regulation
or enforcement sand mining has become a
lucrative business for criminal
organizations in some countries and many
are known to work with businesses and
builders to supply sand for construction
projects and they aren't above using
force to get the sand they want
polygram chohan was a farmer a vegetable
farmer in a little town about an hour
south of new delhi in india huge huge
huge demand for sam in new delhi what
happened was this bunch of goons
basically came to the village one day
seized about 200 acres of the villagers
land just took it over by force ripped
up all their crops stripped out all the
topsoil and started digging up the sand
to sell it to developers polyrhythm
chauhan was kind of a leader in his
village and
you know he tried to get them make them
stop you know he organized protests he
got his fellow villagers together signed
petitions they went to the courts they
went to the cops but they could not get
anybody to take any action mainly
because there's so much corruption in
the system in india as there is a lot of
the developing world it's very easy for
these the sand miners to just spread
around a few bribes and people kind of
look the other way but at a certain
point he was raising enough of a ruckus
that was starting to get under their
skin
so at a certain point these sand miners
took him aside and said look you're
really starting to annoy us you're bad
for business
cut it out shut up or we're going to
kill you
but polyram chohan didn't didn't stop in
fact he reported that threat to the
police three days later somebody burst
into his house while he was taking a nap
and shot him dead in his own bed
so that kind of violence is happening
not only in india but also in ghana in
kenya and indonesia in many many parts
of the world it's local activists like
paoli ram johan it's journalists who've
tried to expose this kind of stuff have
been attacked have been murdered it's a
really really serious issue
as the world's urban centers continue to
expand the demand for sand is expected
to increase putting further pressure on
the world's rivers floodplains and
deltas to meet our demand for sand and
mitigate the negative environmental
effects of mining it engineers and
scientists are looking at developing
more sustainable mining practices and
alternative building materials so my
research team in collaboration with
other researchers at the university of
colorado recently proved that we can
grow a concrete-like alternative we
produced a hybrid living concrete like
building material by leveraging the
biomineralization capabilities of
photosynthetic micro algae we took sand
and mixed that with a little bit of a
hydrogel and inoculated that scaffold
with our biomineralizing algae and what
the algae did is that they precipitated
calcium carbonate little limestone
minerals that helped cement the entire
scaffold structure together and what we
were able to show in our seminal
publication is that not only could the
bacteria that we use help in
manufacturing a concrete-like
alternative we can under certain
conditions keep the bacteria alive and
we showed that you can
actually split this material into two
you can add more sand hydrogel and a
little bit of the nutrients that the
bacteria like and two halves became two
full bricks
and we did that two more times our
living building material technology can
result in materials that have similar
compressive strengths to cementitious
mortars and concretes that are used
today
while our reliance on sand will remain
significant experts say that the keys to
combating the negative effects of sand
mining lie not just in sustainable
mining practices but in gathering more
data too to say that we're running out
of sand is true not in the sense that
there will be no more grains of sand and
every beach on earth will be bare rock
that's not going to happen there's lots
of sand left in the world but
much of the sand that's easy to get at
is gone it's tapped out and so we're
having to go further and further and dig
deeper and deeper and do more and more
harm
to get the sand that we need there is no
silver bullet solution it's going to
take a portfolio
of solutions that are tackling this
problem from every angle and the future
will include the production of portland
cement and it will include the
production of concrete i think there are
things that we can do now and in the
short term such as invest more in the
monitoring and the understanding of the
entire system around sand and then the
policy and the legislation the
requirements the mandates to think about
this issue and use sand more
strategically has to catch up
with the science and the evolving
practices the global south still has to
continue developing so we have to make
sure that we do not completely stifle
the space to develop but then we must do
it in a way that does not harm the
environment if we are looking to
continue to produce concrete and
increase our production of concrete we
will need to look to alternative sources
of fine aggregate because we know that
the earth only has a a certain amount we
all know by now right we're burning way
too much oil we're taking too many fish
out of the oceans we're cutting down too
many trees and now come to find out
we're running out of sand right the most
abundant thing on the planet we consume
too much and by we i really mean we here
in the in the rich developed world and
everybody in the developing world who's
fast catching up to us we've got to find
ways to live our lives and to build our
cities
that just consume less not only of sand
but less of everything
[Music]
you